l'hôpital sainte justine est entré dans
la vie de vincent gariépy en juillet
dernier le plus ému ce propos mais foule
à ségus bien ce système 32 jours est
assez fier après ce cd un énarque de
chaque semaine chez man faiseurs de
vincent l'accompagnent surtout un salon
des ados en ce cas on arrive mais on
sait c'était la méthode ce qui dénote
encore la journée va être longue mais on
est sympathique mais on est gentil si
c'est faux c'est un réconfort dans ma
chance je faisais ça comme ça mais
j'espère et ben je vous donne la job
durable jusqu'aux mais c'est pas pareil
comme quand tu étais petit
la famille a une double histoire avec
l'hôpital sainte justine
parce que la cadette aussi a été
hospitalisé comme bébés prématurés
crosse de maxime et 5,4 lily switcher
celui-ci ben s'est rendu à 14 ans le
président de l'événement puis
il était minuscule puis on t'aimera
c'est partout ça me ramène à ce stress
cette angoisse lapied cette
reconnaissance-là envers une équipe
merveilleuse là j'ai perdu mes cheveux
vincent entreprend un autre traitement
de chimiothérapie
il sait ce qui l'attend il sait aussi
sûr qu'il peut compter ici elles
nourrissent des tati radio canada
montréal